can i say
you look fantastic this man looks and i
want to say something
for a long time it was charming and cool
that you just don't age now it's
frightening
it's like what's going on what do you
know that we don't know well i go out
every year and the cryogenic treatment
frees my tail off in times squares one
of the things nice nice i'm very very
lucky you got the good jeans nothing
beats the good jeans and the hair let's
talk about the hair you are my hair hero
what do you think of mine huh
huh take a good look before you comment
[Applause]
this is freaking you out you're strange
i'm a strange man
might use a little work you work huh
what have you got in there mayonnaise or
something i don't know how you do it
you when you said on the outside your
hair idols were jack lord jack lord from
hawaii five oh yeah or a toupee
no
no
no
no
no no
it'll be all right it'll be all right he
didn't work you pay did he yeah
don't tell me that's a toupee right
there that's real that looks real i can
see that coming out of your skull i
borrowed this for the occasion yeah i'm
checking there are no zippers or buttons
that's all you now the fun part is
everybody's how do you keep it from
going great i've never dyed my hair i
turned on a commercial once they offered
me a lot of money to do the thing about
turning gray
but i had a picture taken the other day
you can see it in this week's tv guide
and it's gray all the way through it
just my daughter says don't stand in
florescent lights but you don't you
don't dye your hair you must have some
deal with satan i don't know what you're
doing
satan's watching right now excellent
clock excellent can can we move beyond
the hair yes
no in fact we won't now that you've
asked
we'll stay and discuss the hair till the
cows come home
american bandstand this was a huge show
you did it for how long how long did you
american band stand for the show was on
for 38 years and i did it for
about 35. that's amazing that's amazing
do people still must associate you with
that show even though you don't do it
now people still must see you and
associate you with that show i love new
york this is my hometown but i walk
around new york we never walk in
california
and people of all ages say hey nikki
baby hello allow you nowadays hey happy
new year early because they know that
thing is coming up right can i tell you
my favorite story true story i did not
make this up i've told it before but
it's a gem
and i've had people of all ages
recognize me
about three years ago i'm in san
francisco
let me tell you
i love san francisco but there are parts
of your town that are sort of frozen in
time
i walk out of a store i bought a pair of
sneakers and i wasn't wearing a tie or
coat or anything not in my television
uniform or anything and i'm feeling
reasonably youthful and out of the midst
of san francisco hills comes this guy
with the long hair and the love beads
and the peace sign and the sandals the
holy an aging hippie kind of comes right
up to my face says my god you're still
alive
that's not right he was he was on his
way to a janis joplin concert
he got delayed in a time warp
let's um let's talk about i i don't know
if this is a touchy area with you've
done very well in show business you've
done extremely well and you have made
you've made a lot of money you are
you're associated with a lot of
different shows you know you probably
own a piece of me and i don't know about
it no okay only good investments uh
you have a lot of you have a lot of cash
you have a lot of money and your
disposal you're going to hit me up for a
loan i want money yes i want money no do
you ever i've heard at the same time
that you're careful with your money you
have quite a bit you have you're saying
in words i'm cheap well that's the
that's what i've heard about dick clark
don't know if it's true it might not be
true let me might be a complete lie
but i've heard he's got a lot of money
and he's tied with it explain to you
okay i was brought up in mount vernon
new york of
people of modest means right mother and
dad never spent a lot of money they
saved their money right and it sort of
worked into my psyche my favorite story
that is i've never confessed this before
but it's true you know these big prize
clubs costco's the places where they
have 17 million cases of stuff you don't
need big boxes of like corn flakes
i go in there one day i come back on a
saturday and say to my wife look
three cases of cat food and i got a
great buy it's like two dollars a cases
it's wonderful but you do know we don't
have a cat
you just bought it because you wanted it
it's true but we did have a dog so the
dog ate the cat food for a while
and liked it too it was a buy how can
you resist them i have a i have an idea
for a television show you were pitching
with david before right i figured
we put it on again saturday night live
on another network i realize it's a
little touchy let's take that show out
no but like
i want to have a big warehouse show
where we got like 17 000 pairs of size
nine and a half reebok sneakers that
have a little imperfection if you get on
the phone you call right away you can
have a dollar ninety eight uh we got
used uh hugos or whatever all weird
stuff uh you know wait a minute well no
disrespectful what's the show just
ringing phones then the phone the whole
show is just ring-ringing oh okay good
yeah yeah you gotta add a sexy element
to it you gotta run down here and we'll
light you on fire like crazy
i'm just trying to you know
if you want to sell it on the fox
network there's got to involve fire
somehow
or you can have the sneakers but we're
going to set these wild dogs after you
and you have to fight the dogs for the
sneakers put some beef in the sneakers
the dog will try and get it clench
clenching
sold many shows lately no not really
i'll get you clark if it's the last
thing i do
now uh new year's rock and eve is coming
up let's talk about this show what uh
who's gonna be on this program uh may i
please we have a gun we have a story
and now i will kill you to promote my
show
we have a three and a half hour
extravaganza and i don't leave anybody
out we have uh nsync jessica simpson
kiss wayne brady is my co-host 98
degrees the bengals the baja man who let
the dogs out who let that off
[Applause]
third eye blind lone star you want to
reprise that yeah yeah vertical horizon
joe oh and my favorite i call him it you
know the most
frequent guest on new year's rock and
eve has been over the years oh
casey in the sunshine yes casey is still
going strong we're going to show his
1976 first appearance very cool it would
be a highlight casey and the sunshine
man and uh you sing on who let the dog
out i heard
uh no that's not you that's the rumor
i'm starting dick clarks
dick clark's new year's rock and eve is
on abc at 10 o'clock p.m it's on this
sunday dick thanks so much for for
coming by and saying hi to happy new
year happy new year clark everybody